الان معنا من بورسودان فولكر بيرت رئيس
بعثه الامم المتحده لدعم في السودان اهلا
بك يعني بدايه كيف تقراون من جهتكم هذه
الازمه وتطورات المشهد السوداني والى اي
مدى كان متوقعا هذا التطور في هذا المشهد
من طرفكم
مساء الخير
كانت وارخه ولكن ما كان في كما يقولون
انذار مبكر انه المعارك ستبدا يوم السبت
صباحا ولكن طبعا كنا كنا واعيين مدركين عن
خطوره الوضع تقريبا من اسبوعين قبل 15
ابريل بدا انا يعني بكل جهودنا لمساهمه في
في خفض التصعيد باين الجيش والدعم السريع
فحثينا على على بعد الدول المنطقه المهمه
ان ان
تستضيف
الرئيس برهان والجنر الهمتي
فتتوسط
بيناتهم
فطبعا يعني احنا كمان يعني بوسائلنا كنا
على اتصال مباشر مع الجنرلين كل الوقت كنا
ننادي الى الى خفض التوتر وكنا نشرخ كيف
خطير الوضع عن كل يعني كل حادث يمكن يفجر
يفجر استلام عسكري حتى يوم الجمعه حتى يوم
الجمعه كنا نجتمع يعني لاربع ساعات مع احد
القاعده وقت قصير ما قادر من الطرف الثاني
فالمدنيين بعض الاطراف المدنيه فعلوا نفس
الشيء
يعني فوافقت الطرفين على تشكيل لجنه
عسكريه كان كان مفروض يجتمع يوم السبت
طبعا هذا لا يتم لانه يوم السبت يعني بدات
المعارك يعني وقد اشرت الى خطوره هذا
الوضع الى اي مدايا دق ناقوس الخطر بتطور
اخطر قد يدخل البلاد بنفق مظلم
بالتاكيد السودان حاليا بالنفقه
طبعا كل نفقه لها
مخرج كمان فالمخرج حاليا في وقف اطلاق نار
في هدنه
هدنه يعني مشروطه
او خلينا
منظم يعني باليه لمراقبه
الهدنه ووقفه لكن عاش لازم تشارك فيه طبعا
الاتراف المتسارعين
فيجب ان يجتمع ان يشارك فيه يعني رقابه
بمراقبه بمراقبه
بمراقبه الهدنه يعني لازم تشارك فيه بعض
الاطراف الدوليه ويمكن من اهم يعني اطراف
محليه يعني من المجتمع المدني ولجان
المقاومه
والتنظيمات المسلحه تنسيماته كفاعله يعني
كل الموجودين على الارض
ثانيين يعني خارج السودان حتى
يمكن يعني نتصل مع الاطراف بالهاتف اذا في
خط ولكن اذا بدك عرب مراقبه بدك يعني شيء
على الارض
التواصل مع هذه الاطراف وبوضع هذه الاليات
يعني كيف يمكن الزام اطراف الصراع في
السودان بها كيف يمكن ان ضمان هذا
الالتزام بها
الدماغ بنهايه يعني عند السوريين
السودانيين انفسهم ولكن يعني كمان
كل الدول كل دول المنطقه ودول العالم يعني
لازم ان
لازم ان يقولون يعني بكل القوه انه اذا
استمر هذه الحاله
فحتى اذا انتصر جهه على جهه ثانيه
فستكون
ستكون جهه مرفوضه دوليا يعني اذا اذا اذا
جحا هلا
ترفت المفوذات اذا جهت ترفد المسالخه فما
ما تكون مقبوله يعني دوليا واقليميا وانا
بتات وهذا اهم اجتماعيا او مجتمعيا في
السودان
الحل في وقت فوري دائم بدون وقفه لا كنار
ستكون هناك فاهوده في
مشفقه في خاتون وفي السودان ناس بدهم
امدادات المستشفيات بدهن امدادات
فيعني هذا هذا ممكن فقط اذا في وصول امن
يعني للاسواق ووصول امن للمستشفيات
والى اخره فلذلك وقفه لك فوري هذا هو الخط
الاول الخطوه الاولى بعدين مفوضات
السياسيه بين الجنرلين يعني بعين الجيش
وبين دعم السريع وبعدين
لم تحقق اهدافها هذه الهدى ما مدى تفاؤلكم
بصمود هذه الهدنه الخامسه وربما تمديد هذه
الهدنه وما هي الضمانات انا سالتك عن
الضمانات قلت بانهم السودانيون انفسهم لكن
اذا كان السودانيون انفسهم يعني هم اطراف
الصراع ما هي الضمانات الدوليه للالتزام
بهذه الهدن ووقف النار ومن ثم التفاوض كما
تقول
يعني ما في قوات دوليه او اجنبيه في
السودان ولذلك يعني الدمان بمعنى عسكري
يعني غير موجود
ما هو ممكن
هو اليه
لمراقبه وتنفيذ وقفه لكنهار مع اشارات
واضحه لمن يخرج
الهدنه مع قيود وقواعد وارخه ما هو مسموخ
وما هو غير مسموخ في هدنه مثلا يعني
التحرك قوات او الكناسه يعني مسموخ يعني
هذا هذا لازم ان يحدد الاطراف لازم ان
يوافقوا على على هذه الشعوب وبعدين نخت
الى الى اليه مراقبه كي كي نقول يعني
بصراحه لانه في اذا في خروقات يعني اي جهه
خرجت
اتفاق اتفاقيه اتفاق وقفه بلاك نار ومن هي
الاطراف التي يمكن ان تشرف على هذه
الاليات ويمكنها ان تشارك في هذه العمليه
انا انه احسن شيء اذا شاركت في هذه
العمليه
جهات اقليميه ودوليه يعني دول المنطقه
مثلا والاتحاد الافريقي
فكمان ادفع في الدوليه منها الامم المتحده
ومنها بعد الدول
عندهم عندهم قوه وعندهم عندهم تاثير مباشر
على
على الطرف الواحد والطرف الثاني او
الطرفين منها الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
والسعوديه
وبريطانيا والامارات مثلا هو مصر كمان
يعني لها تاثير
ولكن هذه الاطراف الاجنبيه اقليميه كانت
او دوليه لا تكفي المهم انه في اي اله
اليه مراقبه كي تكون لحم مصداقيه فالمجتمع
السوداني تشارك فيه هم اللي يرون مع ما
يحدث يعني كل واحد يعني كل كل كل زول
سوداني عنده
عنده تليفون عنده هاتف سمارت فون فيمكن
يراكب يمكن يرسل يعني الى
السكرتاريه هكذا
اصوات مما يخص يعني بدون يعني مشاركه
فعاله للاخزاب لجانب مقاومه للتنزيمات
المسلحه
يعني تدميك هكذا هكذا اليه المراقبه
يعني فيما يتعلق بالبعد الانساني وقد اشرت
اليه ولكل صراع وحرب بعدها الانسان
وتداعياتها الانسانيه وهناك تحذيرات ايضا
محليه اقليميه دوليه مما هو اسوا ما هي
اولوياتكم فيما يتعلق بهذا الجانب وكيف
تتعاملون
مع هذه التحديات
يبدو اننا فقدنا السيد
وهو رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
السودان سيد هل مازلت تسمعنا
هل تسمعني
اذا شكرا جزيلا لك من بورتسودان فالكبرت
رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعمي في
السودان